how's it going everybody Rob and Aaron
here we've had a bunch of time with far
cry 5 messed around with all of the
weapons and we're here with some
recommendations for our favorites mm-hmm
quick note some of the ones that we
recommend here our prestige weapons but
all of these were bought with in-game
currency we didn't spend any real-world
money and all of these look cool but
they have like half-price generic
counterpart versions in the store in the
game so you can earn any of these
weapons just by playing yeah like for
instance the 44 Magnum steel and ivory
that would be one I think you could get
that skin through pre-order but it is
the exact same as this other
counterparts the cheap rubber variants
but yeah it looks cool so if you're able
to have that weapon at your disposal and
go for it the first gun that we want to
talk about is the Magna pulsar which is
really cool so you get this gun from the
Larry Parker set of missions he's a mad
scientist he has you do a bunch of
chores for him and then he vanishes into
the what we're only assuming is Mars dlc
next you can see posters all over his
office of the upcoming mars dlc for far
cry 5 but the magnet pulsar is a really
important gun in this game in my opinion
because after you take your first regen
the bat the tempo picks up a lot and you
end up running out of ammo quite a lot
and the magnet pulsar has unlimited
amounts of ammo now it takes some
getting used to it's a like a physics
based gun that knocks enemies over when
you fire it at the ground but it just
vaporizes enemies at point-blank range
any enemy that's not a heavy heavy ones
you have to whittle them down before
it'll vaporize them now the cool thing
about this is you can also use it for
like hunting and melee challenges you
can knock people over and then beat them
to death or like this week's live event
you can knock people over and set them
on fire mmm so it's actually a really
fun tool to use but yeah like if you
don't get right on somebody it won't
vaporize them and if it does vaporize
them you can't loot them so it does have
some drawbacks I feel like you were
using some of those like buffs or perks
right that could feasibly launch people
farther like that give you strength and
stuff right yeah I mean you can always
use the fast and the furious and I have
two different drugs in the game that
that make you stronger with melee and
also make you much faster so you can
close distance particularly because you
have to get some
to use this gun but it wound up being my
go-to and one of my favorite weapons not
to mention it was made by probably by
aliens is that yeah he can't speak to
other weapons on that note yeah if I
were to say anything regarding the rat
for rocket launcher is that it's a must
I don't know the name of the other
rocket launcher but you're gonna want
the rat for over any other kind of RPG
or explosive type weapons in that it's
got if you attach a scope to it it's got
a B lock on a ability to like lock onto
vehicles or its self-guided you know
similar to like half-life 2 like the
rock launchers and that that was really
funny when I bought it I was like why
would a rocket launcher have a scope I
don't need this and they'd even bother
to look at it until you came by and and
to my desk and you're like dude this
thing totally locks onto airplanes yeah
which is great because those pesky
airplanes can like just interrupts
whatever the hell you're doing and just
a quick lock on and then it's like a set
it forget it type of deal and then the
kicker is something that we found out a
little late is that it's got a secondary
ammo type which is a cluster rocket or a
incendiary cluster rocket either or
these things are freaking awesome they
will just buy carpet bomb a large area
so again it's just like almost like a
surface like to air and then it drops
down and yeah just carpet bombs a whole
mass area so if you have the
incendiaries one - you can just light up
an outpost pretty easily I think the
first time that we actually fired this
while writing the script we were both
like oh my god seriously it was like
alright this is a winner
just to add you have to buy the black
market perk in order to be able to buy
those Rockets so if you don't see those
Rockets in the game they're not
craftable you just have to get the black
market park and then make money by
killing animals and then buy these
cluster rockets yeah totally all right
so the next one that I wanted to talk
about this has been an obsession of mine
since the division which is to take two
light machineguns with you packing a
hundred and sixty rounds each and make
your friends think that the game is
broken because you're just continually
firing for like three minutes straight I
actually had people in the division just
turn around and look at me because I
hadn't reloaded in several minutes and
had just fired continuously
so you can't you can't go full Rambo you
can't hold them out at the same time
unfortunately can't go akimbo but if you
pull out the m16 the m249 militia with
vehicle Buster perk which does more
damage to vehicles you can tear through
any outposts in just a matter of seconds
without having to stop to do pesky
things like reload
yeah totally that that's not necessarily
my style and I feel like the next weapon
would follow up with like another
solution because like I I mean that's
definitely one way to do it right just
go in guns blazing on the flip though
the sharkbite the AR CL is one of my
favorites in that even like for like the
earlier game where you have just two
weapon slots you want to take priority
right or like what am I actually
bringing in I want like I want to have
that versatility right I want to have
long and short range this weapon kind of
meets both in the respect that it is
technically a sniper rifle but you have
the ability to switch fire rates so you
can you know you can start off and
attack put a silencer on and start
picking off you know any any dudes near
like alarms and so forth and then move
in and swap to like a burst fire or
fully-auto and clean up an outpost I
just find it like very versatile again
and it's just like if you're trying to
have that extra slot for like you know a
rat for whatever other type of weapon
this one kind of meets both I want to
say long and short range maybe it's not
the best sniper rifle but it gets the
job done like that like I've got from a
medium the long range it will definitely
like be useful it sounds like a good
multi-tool yeah and I think as you
mentioned very early in the game
particularly in your first region you
have I believe only two weapon slots
right so not having to take a sniper
rifle and an assault rifle with you just
getting that down to one weapon slot and
the other weapon slot being and launcher
is pretty critical yeah definitely the
next one that we're gonna bring up is
the spaz 12 we picked the flameout
shotgun prestige variant of it but
there's again
there's just like a generic in the store
this shotgun has the fastest rate of
fire in the game and particularly when
you combine it with incendiary rounds
this thing is a beast
the range is surprisingly good it's
maybe 15 feet
you can still one-shot enemies but I
can't tell you how many times you know
like just a truckload of dudes rolled up
on me and they all went down before
getting out of the truck or this thing
is a serious bear killer if you're
trying to do those grizzly challenges
yeah just walk up and and light it up
with a spazz 12 and you will have your
hunting challenge completed hell yeah
again I for one am a big fan of sniping
I think the ultimate sniper rifle is the
Free State again the yeah this is the
prestige skin variant the SI 50 but I
think it's just your all-around solid
sniper compared to other ones I know
there's like a 50 Cal a slower rate
fired or there's like a bolt-action
version of it this one's semi-auto with
a clip right so when you're when you're
like aim down sights and you're firing
you're not getting like a ton of recoil
like you're able to like get one or two
shots off cuz I'm I mean I'm not an
expert sniper but it can get frustrating
when you missed that shot and there's
like that delay of like you know yeah as
you said bolt-action reloading seeing
your scope you know fly up in the air as
you're like trying to like then readjust
your shot it's got a good fire rate and
it's all-around solid it's like my go-to
for sure as far as sniping you'd mention
that you really like sniper rifles and
when I picked up the first 308 I wasn't
that impressed with it and throw oh this
one came along and this one gets the job
done
toilet
next is the yeah 44 Magnum steel in
ivory again this is the skin that does
come with the pre-order but there are
like two other variants with the same
stats I just for one I'm a big fan of
magnums in general and if you're gonna
have a pistol slot why not go with a
hand cannon there's something gratifying
about a 44 Magnum and if pistol I don't
know like if I'm gonna pull out
something and finish off a bear it's
gonna be this guy so speaking of the
pistol slot the only grenade launcher
that can go in the pistol slot and this
is the nice version of it but the m79
shark shooter is a it's a pretty dang
good grenade launcher so I'm really good
when you're getting ambushed by trucks
on the road if you're good with it you
can hit helicopters and airplanes but
it's really important that it's in that
pistol slot because again especially
early on in the game you don't have the
ability to take very many weapons with
you having a grenade launcher with you
at all times
is awesome the catch being that then you
have to also worry if you run out of
primary ammo you you better get good
with other things like the shovel which
is so satisfying no for sure like in my
opinion if you don't pick up like an RPG
like the rat 4 this is probably where
you want to go to just to have one of
the other in my opinion like again yeah
great great use for like taking down
vehicles but also like crowd control I
feel like with a sharp shooter like you
know if you have like a bunch of those
list up jackasses like this guy will put
them to shame for sure
so those are some of our favorite
weapons so far in Far Cry 5 obviously
there are a lot of play styles in this
game and we didn't actually even cover
if you're a stealth player so we would
love to hear from you guys what weapons
are you primarily using in Far Cry we
had a couple that didn't make the cut
that we were like we enjoyed but we
weren't really sure about such as the
slingshot so if you use any of these
weapons definitely tell us about it in
the comments below
and thanks for watching guys thank you
you